simon clark chief secretary to the
treasury uh is with us hello to you mr
clark your reaction good morning
well these are obviously extremely
distressing images and i think
everyone's hearts will go out to the
families affected by by this awful event
what it goes to show clearly is that
we've got a lot of work to do to help uh
mitigate this sort of extreme climate
events that we're now witnessing and and
this is a reminder today i think of the
importance of tackling climate change
because this is a remarkable
unprecedented event uh and something
which obviously as people have been
saying we are not used to seeing in this
country what we what we've seen over
recent days is not normal and it is it
is a warning sign
you said that delivering net zero is
hugely important and and yet you're
backing this trust who wants to suspend
the green levy which would help in
trying to get to net zero so so how do
you square that circle
that's a one-year mitigation designed to
save families about 150 pounds off their
energy bills at a time when obviously
the cost of living is so
uh is is such an important issue but liz
is completely clear she stands by our
commitment to delivering net zero by uh
2050 and that is obviously something
which this government is working
at pace to deliver we have a 30 billion
pound net zero strategy about changing
our uh energy system in particular but
also of course a shift from petrol and
diesel cars to electric cars all of
these things are are crucial if we're to
make sure that we uh we indeed uh do our
bit as a country to make to make uh good
on ourselves
the paris climate accord yeah just
sure just looking at those pictures
doesn't matter whether they're
electrical or diesel or petrol they're
all uh burnt to a cinder what are you
going to do to help these people
well obviously people will have uh
insurance but the government will be
looking carefully at what we can do to
to make sure that everyone receives the
support they need and obviously the
first thing is to make sure that they
uh that they have the the support in in
the very immediate term people may have
lost all their belongings as we've heard
their identity documents uh and and i
know our local councils will be stepping
up uh to look after people who've been
affected across uh the country by fires
but clearly central government stands
ready as always to uh
to step in as as needed
yeah so people don't have insurance
you'll help them
i i'm absolutely certain the government
will look at whatever is needed to do to
make sure that people are are looked
after at a time like this clearly it's
not for me to comment on specific cases
i'm not asking you to comment on
specific cases but you are giving me a
massive generalization i'm saying if
these people wake up this morning in
this premiere in behind me and they find
out they've literally only got the
clothes they're standing up in and they
don't have any insurance will you help
them
the government will stand by people who
need assistance after an emergency event
as we always do
okay talk to me about liz
truss
accusations of
dirty deals vote lending going on um
yesterday it seemed strange that um
rishi soon act only put on three votes
to 118
um to get down to the finals free
there's been some vote lending going on
the most important thing is that uh liz
is within touching distance now of those
those final two spots at which point
obviously this reverts to the the
membership of the conservative party the
200 000 party members to choose our next
prime minister i've absolutely uh no
insight into any of this as far as i can
see my
my only goal uh as colleagues is to make
sure that the best candidate goes
forward to the members and in my clear
view that is
that is liz and our campaign has been
focused purely and simply on making that
case to our colleagues and and crucially
that's that's succeeding and we want
obviously to continue that that hard
work into today to make sure liz gets
into those final two
to final two slots and gets to make a
case to the membership
yeah uh nothing illegal about vote
lending though is there we certainly saw
that it uh helped boris johnson during
the last leadership campaign do you
think it's happened i i i've no uh
insight into it to anything of that kind
colleagues ultimately vote for the
person they think is best place to be
uh the next party leader that's the only
possible right thing to do and the only
logical thing to do and uh i all i'm
focused on today is making sure that we
make the case to as many colleagues as
possible that if they want a robust plan
for economic growth so they want strong
defense spending if they want clear
action on the climate then they should
be voting for uh for liz
and you you don't see it as um
surprising at all that uh rishi soon
only put on three votes
well look it's not for me to comment on
what any other campaign might be doing
we're focused as a campaign i'm making
sure that uh we make the positive case
for
liz and she's got a fantastic story to
tell and we've got just a few hours left
now to make sure that we
uh get liz into those final two slots
and as i say make sure that she gets her
chance to make her pitch to the
conservative party membership
we're being told that you all want to
clean a campaign um i know that lord
frost tweeted about penny mordent
warning um that she basically wasn't up
to the job um and you retweeted that and
said that it was a serious warning do
you think that's fair play
i think it's very important that people
get to hear about the assessment of the
uh qualities of people who are standing
not just to be the next leader of the
conservative party but our next prime
minister and and lord frost's warning is
not in isolation it's been echoed by a
number of people i think it's perfectly
important that people who have as i say
work closely with candidates get to uh
get to make clear their views this is
this is a robust contest you would
expect it to be frankly because this is
an incredibly important job and uh
people's readiness for that job on day
one is critical that that is of course
one of the reasons why i'm supporting
the foreign secretary someone who's
tested in the highest office and has
held a series of uh secretary of state
ships
okay what happened with tobias elwood
why has he had the whip removed when 12
other mps weren't there either
well there are
there are look i'm not a member of the
whips office but what i would say is
that there are clear arrangements in
place which all mps understand which
govern the conditions uh for absence
from
votes and of course most especially from
critical votes like emotion of of
confidence in the government which has
the potential to trigger a general
election uh you can you can either get
permission for extenuating circumstances
people may be ill or have loved ones who
are ill
or they may have very very important
life events as i understand it mr elwood
was warned about uh the the seriousness
of his absence he was on a a foreign
visit uh it was within his power to
return to the united kingdom to vote
uh he was in ukraine
and we believe ukraine is uh number one
on the prime minister's list he's trying
to sort out getting this grain out of
odessa so doing government work he was
in the middle of a bomb threat and the
airport that he would have gone back
into the tarmac had melted so it was
shot
he was in moldova as i understand rather
than ukraine he wasn't on government
work he's not a government minister he
is a backbench mp and he was asked to
return to the united kingdom for a
confidence vote which was well committed
chairman of the defense committee okay
this vote was well cross about it okay
i'm not getting across i'm simply
correcting the record on this he's not
he's not a government minister he's a
backbench mp that this vote was known
about well into last chairman of these
different
that doesn't matter for these purposes
this is a vote of confidence in
imaginative government and that trumps
all other businesses what about the
other 11 what about the other 12 mps
then who weren't there either kay i'm
not privy to the personal circumstances
of all of those mps but there are very
pressing reasons often why colleagues
cannot be there people may be ill as i
say they may have loved ones who are ill
crucially that's for the whips office to
determine they will determine who has
legitimate reasons for absence and who
doesn't this was a vote which was known
about days in advance and mr elwood
chose to go to moldova that was his
decision but ultimately it is also i'm
afraid to say a very a very serious
mistake